لقد تم تشويه حكمنا للإسلام بشكل فادح من
خلال اتخاذ المتطرفين ليكون المعيار
القائل بأن السيدات
والسادة خطأ فادح
يمكن أن يتفقوا معك
على عكس العديد منكم أنا لست خبيرًا في
الإسلام على الرغم من أنني مسرور
لأسباب أتمنى أن تصبح  من الواضح
أن تكون راعيًا لمركز أكسفورد
للدراسات الإسلامية ،
فالمركز لديه القدرة على أن يكون
وسيلة مهمة ومثيرة
لتعزيز وتحسين
فهم العالم الإسلامي في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
لتتمكن من زيارة أفضل حياة
على الأقل كانت من أجلها
لي فرحة كبيرة
وأنا
أقدر
كثيرا فرصة لقاء قطاع عريض من
الشعب الفلسطيني
خلال زيارتي القصيرة
والاستماع إلى شيء
من حياتهم والتحديات التي
يواجهونها ،
يجب علينا التمييز بين أنظمة
العدالة التي تدار بنزاهة
وأنظمة  العدالة
كما قد نراهم تمارس والتي
تم تشويهها لأسباب سياسية إلى
شيء لم يعد إسلاميًا
لك